hello everyone welcome to today's live
broadcast polyamines and bacterial
growth and biofilm formation I'm Judy
O'Rourke of lab roots and I'll be your
moderator for today's event we are
delighted to bring you this educational
web seminar presented by labyrinth more
information please visit lab roots com
we have a few important announcements
before we begin this webcast is designed
to be interactive and we encourage you
to ask questions during the event you
can submit questions by typing them in
the Q&A box which can be found by
clicking on a green Q&A button at the
lower left of the presentation window
we'll try to answer as many questions as
we can you can enlarge the slide window
by clicking on the screen icon in a
lower right hand corner of the slide
window if you have any technical
problems viewing or hearing this
presentation please click on the support
button at the top right of your
presentation window or submit your
problem through the green Q&A button
lower left I would now like to introduce
today's speaker dr. Anthony Michael dr.
michael is an associate professor in the
department of pharmacology at the
University of Texas Southwestern Medical
Center in Dallas his current research
focuses from identification of novel
biosynthetic pathways for polyamines and
polyamine containing molecules and the
role of these compounds in bacterial
growth and biofilm formation he is
particularly interested in Hell
biosynthetic pathways and their
associated enzymes evolve is also an
editor of the journal of biological
chemistry and on the advisory board of
the biochemical journal I will now turn
it over to dr. Michael for his
presentation
Thank You Julie and hello from Dallas
and it's a very nice warm day here so
today I'm going to talk to you about
very interesting molecules called poly
innings many people haven't here to poly
means even though they're found in all
cells and they are very important in
advanced organisms but today I'm going
to talk primarily about poly means in
bacterial growth and bio information now
i'm going to divide my talk into five
sections i'm going to describe what poly
means are and I need to explain to you
why poly means are essential in
eukaryotes like us humans and then I'll
be able to talk about the role of poly
means and bacteria which is very
different to the role of poly means in
animals and plants and I'm going to talk
you about pilings and bacterial biofilm
formation and finally I'm going to talk
about small controversy which is in the
pointing by chrome field now Holly Mimas
first of all are derived from amino
acids so all poly means no matter what
structure they are derived from amino
acids and the key feature opponent is
that they are positively charged at
physiological pH and this is a very
important aspect of their physical
chemical activity the most common in
poly means are producing and spiriting I
just had a question of its ebb you can't
see the slides but I think that's not my
problem so in all life the most common
poly means of producing and spending
which I'll explain that
a little bit about in a moment and the
important thing about spiriting is that
it's essential for all eukaryotic life
and probably for all our kale life now
it's not often you can cite a paper from
1678 but poly means were first observed
in 1678 by Anthony Van Loon hunk who
invented the microscope and he saw
looking at samples of seminal fluid is
for crystals and at the time he didn't
know but those crystals were spermine
phosphate and in seminal fluid spermine
is present at about 17 mm mm less a very
high physiological concentration so the
first paper of our poly means was over
three hundred thirty years ago and
here's the structure of the precursor
putting in kerosene and the physical
physiologically active putting in sperm
again this is a space-filling
representation of the molecules and i'm
going to show you an alternative
representation in a moment but the
important thing to realize about these
molecules is that blue atoms are any
means nitrogen group and these are the
groups that are positively charged at
physiological ph the other thing is that
spermidine is flexible so it's it's not
linear as you see it in this
representation but it moves and quite
rapidly here's an alternative
representation of the structure of
progressing and spermidine and the
important thing to see is that
spermidine is simply progressing with an
amino propyl group added on to it and
it's very important for the rest of the
talk to remember that one psychics
pyrimidine is in a beautiful site which
has four carbons and the other side is
the aminopropyl side which has three
carbons
and so Pedro seeing this symmetrical
imaging is the core and symmetrical
chemical speech why is permitting
essential for the growth of eukaryotic
cells so if you do not spermidine at the
top the immune of butyl group is present
in red or if you are colorblind on the
right hand side the portion with four
carbons is the immuno butyl group at a
minute butyl group is transferred to a
lysing side chain of a translation
factor called ef5 a and that transfer of
the middle butyl group is performed by
an enzyme called deoxyribose in
incentives and the modification of the
lysing in the fiv forms a unique amino
acid coral of the oxy hydrazine which is
subsequently hydroxylated the from
immature hydrazine modification now
there is only one protein in all
eukaryotes that is modified by spending
like that it's ef5 a and there's only
one amino acid in a five-way that's
modified yet this modification is
absolutely essential for all eukaryotic
life in fact if you not go up at the
oxidizing synthase gene or if you're not
got pregnant by synthesis then there is
no group released and there is immediate
arrest of ember development in mice the
important thing about this modification
called hydrogenation which is dependent
upon spermatic is that it allows the
ribosome to translate messages message
RNA RNAs which encode proteins
containing poly prolene tracks that is a
protein which has several proteins in a
row several proteins in a row agency a
key thing about problem is that when
it's incorporated into a protein it
changes the direction of the peptide
chain so when you have three or four
proteins consecutively
protein it kinks the nascent peptide
chain in the ribosome and the ribosome
will store all at the polyprotein track
unless ef5 a is there to allow it to
pass through this blockage of the
polypropylene tract so this unique
modification is essential for all
eukaryotic life and probably for RKO
life as well so spermidine the
archetypal poly mean is absolutely
essential and we know at least one of
the essential functions so there may be
other essential functions experimenting
and certainly in humans for instance
boumediene is a precursor for a longer
Polly Nichols firming which is also
essential but for completely different
reasons now bacteria do not possess ef5
a however they have a translation factor
that is analogous called efp and rather
than being modified by am experimenting
EFP is modified by lysing to you
sterilizing entre lysing the process
called lies innovation because if up
friday is not present in bacteria that
means that there's no known conserved
essential function of poly means
bacteria and that means that bacteria
have a lot of freedom as it were to do
different things with poly means now not
only the bacteria not modify if I they
were spending but it bacteria there are
three different structural analogues
building one is called nor spending and
is one carbon shorter rinse ability the
other version is called homeless
permitting and it's one carbon longer
than sperma dean so the designation sim
means shorter sorry designation just
means that the symmetrical North
vomiting the designation law in poly
means which means shorter hormone means
one common long
now if you look to the right hand side
of the structures you'll see that los
pyrimidine is relatively unusual it's
found in vibrio species such as liberal
caller ID which causes colorado action
it's also found in hyper filmer files
bacteria that live extremely high
temperatures such as thermus
thermophilus but on the whole is not
found in many bacteria spermidine is
found in most bacteria and homeless
boumediene is found sporadically amongst
bacteria but for instance you do find it
in important pathogens such as brucella
Legionella and coxiella proxy latvian
causative agent of Q fever brucella
cause improve services and vision ever
being accosted causative agent of
Legionnaires disease so already we can
see that in bacteria there's a diversity
of poly means relative gene carriers and
the other thing about bacteria is that
they have many more ways to make POI
immunes and your carrots and they make
more probably means different types of
oils but something that's a little
unusual is that the same pathway can be
used to make different aliens different
poly means can be made from the same
pathway and this diversity means that
several pathways have evolved present
and experimenting that are not usually
related so it means they've evolved by
convergent evolution to make the same
molecule also be a different columnist
that exists play similar functions so
there's a diversity of structure poly
means and a diversity of making them all
of which are convergent and so this
indicates that there's a very strong
English we pressure to evolve pointed by
synthesis one could say that the
evolution of poly means is almost
inevitable in life because life has
amino acids proteins derived from amino
acids
there's a Nevitt ability that a multiple
stages during evolution of life polymers
have independently evolved I don't
expect you to be able to read this slide
this is really just to give an
indication some of the complexity of
protein biosynthesis on the left hand
side there is a pathway to mix
permitting that uses
s-adenosylmethionine as the eventual
donor for the amino propyl group that is
added on to producing team experimenting
on the right hand side is a pathway that
uses aspartic be descending peter semi
aldehyde to donate amino propyl group
now as part it's because semi aldehyde
is an intermediate in lysing laughing in
a training biosynthesis acid on some
refining is a critically important
molecule in a cell that is mainly known
as a neutral donor but in the case of
poly means essentially an amino profile
donor commerce building which is in the
center going upwards that is made again
by completely different pathway and it
can be made by two completely different
thomas buildings and phrases so we have
to part ways to mix permitting we have
to part ways to make homer spinning and
spinning and los pyrimidine can be made
by the same pathway starting with
different precursors one of the reasons
why Pauline is a not very well known
many molecular biologists are not
familiar with them is that they're a
little bit difficult to work with
because measuring them and detecting
them is not straightforward and you have
to first of all modifying the prod
inning with some kind of chemical moiety
that can actually be seeming hot unions
can't be seen by light so with
derivatives opponents that is we can pre
modify them for instance by reacting
them with benzyl chloride or with
danceOn chloride or with how aldehyde
or with a commercial a cute AG regent
and that renders the pudding reactive to
light saw and polymers can be seen by
fluorescence or occasionally by UV light
so fluorescence is that are very
sensitive and most people use hplc to
detect proteins you can actually use and
Findlay a chromatography which is much
cheaper but doesn't have the same
sensitivity or discrimination now we
separate the poly means on the reverse
phase hydrophobic column and the
different polymers come up a column with
a chocolate at different times and we
can then relate the elution time
resolution time of chemically
synthesized poisonings and if we have
pure peterson and something that looks
at the same time as pure progressing
it's likely to be producing
alternatively we can detect parliament
without derivatives a shin directly by
mass spectrometry at the separation by a
liquid chromatography now I'm going to
start talking about the role of poly
means and bacterial growth and I'm going
to do it primarily from some important
papers that first established a rope of
poly poly means in the growth of
different species of bacteria this is a
figure from a paper that's now 12 years
old by the japanese group of mccarter
and ito and they looked at the
opportunistic pathogen pseudomonas
aeruginosa and they knocked out the
genes that make pit racing in this
organism so when you knock out peterson
you can no longer an expert in and on
the left-hand side at the bottom you can
see that they've not got the genes Bay a
and Spacey which including eco box
lasers that make peterson and on the
right-hand side at the bottom they've
knocked out and
one of the decarboxylase is and two
enzymes further down the pathway you'll
notice that without poly means in the
poem in depleted medium there is very
little growth compared to the wild type
curve at the top and the wild type
strain from the presence of one minimal
of using now the scale is a logarithmic
scale so and this growth difference
between with poly means of outputting
Eunice's very large and we can say that
claimants are essential for protocol
pseudomonas aeruginosa i should mention
that any work to do with polyphenols and
trying to figure out what poly means or
in any given bacterium requires you to
work with chemically defying a medium
because normal growth medium like LD a
medium or a tryptic soy broth or t y
medium they contain a lot of
experimenting from either yeast extract
or from soy bean extract so it's very
important when you work with party means
to work with chemically defined medium
otherwise bacteria have probably uptake
transporters and they will take up poly
means from the medium and that will
confuse your identification of
doggedness poisonous i recently had to
make a comment on a paper that was
published with a comment in pubmed
collings because a mexican group claimed
to have found loss permanent staff
Apophis aureus but they grew the
bacterium in tryptic soy broth which is
known to contain colleen's so we know
for sure that stapler caucus does not
make it some point every sort of bets
pseudomonas aeruginosa which is a very
robust bacterium so i must admit with
this paper first came out i was
surprised that something so robust were
so dependent upon poly means now and
this figure I apologize for the
complexity of it it's figure from one of
my own papers and it's of the food
poisoning back team compiler back Reggie
journey
the red line at the bottom is the growth
of a mutant of compiler compiler back to
do journey where we knocked out the
first enzyme in the polymn pathway and
in black at the top is the wild-type any
language contains them sperma d so when
you remove the ability to mix permit in
from compiler back 30 Jenny and you
essentially polished off the green line
at the top is the mutant at the bottom
which has been given spill ready till in
compiler back 30 journey which is a so
called epsilon quarter bacterium
spermidine is an essential molecule of
life as it is in pseudomonas aeruginosa
so in contrast that here's a paper from
the table group published a couple of
years ago oh there's already six years
of a good boy so in this paper they
showed that if you knock out climbing by
synthesis in E coli which is an
incredibly difficult thing to do because
prot air ecola has multiple pathways to
Napoleon's and it also makes several
different poly means so it required
knocking out a lot of jeans for what
minus chatter pod I was able to show was
that when you knock out all poly means
from proline and you're getting
chemically defined the medium which is
quite free is about a forty percent
decrease in the growth rate but
nevertheless it can grow essentially
forever without problems and this is
quite surprising considering the result
in pseudomonas however we know from our
own experience these results are
absolutely correct that equal i will
grow slower without poly means but will
grow and almost indefinitely now this is
the effect of knocking out timing
biosynthesis in the gram-positive
bacterium bacillus surface
and these figures are taken from one of
our papers if you look on the left you
can see the proof of the white light
bacterium which is called 168 this is a
laboratory string of bacillus otras and
the red line is a mutant which has the
arginine eco box Liz gene knocked out
and so it can't make proteins and the
blue line is a gene that is similar to
the Argentine decarboxylase but turns
out to be not important point in bio
synthesis but anyway when you knock out
Conley biosynthesis and you can see on
the right-hand side and hplc trace of
the poly means in the wild type in black
and the mutant in red you will notice
the sperm in peak of the wild-type is
completely absent in the spay a mutant
which can't wait for tables so we know
that these bacteria the mutant doesn't
contain any part in you and yet it grows
perfectly happily at the same rate as
the wild-type so in bacillus there is no
requirement at all for poly means in
planktonic growth that is growth in a
liquid culture and of course this is a
very unusual situation because a
socialist does not grow in 200 mil
conical flask hungry in in the wild but
nevertheless in this laboratory
situation you don't need poly means for
growth in bacillus Phil just to
summarize a little bit about the rulings
and different types of bacteria where AM
papers have been published on knocking
out Pony encryption and where poly means
unknown to be essential for any growth
student nurse originals own compiler
back dirty journey and an unpublished
find in a crack team team officiants
which is finding of play football in
university of indiana and we've
collaborated with where polymers are
required for normal growth over so if
you knock upon your production gets low
coli Salmonella you say pestis which is
the plague bacterium the body plague and
the blue collar and where you don't
require poly means for growth at all the
settlers Steffler caucus aureus and
streptococcus pneumoniae know you will
notice at the bottom restless stubble
caucus and streptococcus or all crammed
positive bacteria is they only have one
cell membrane and one of the features of
the gram-positive bacteria that you have
your gastrointestinal tract is that many
of the gram-positive bacteria in your
gut have lost the ability to nick poly
means but appointing transporters to
take a poly so in the case of
staphylococcus aureus and streptococcus
pneumoniae they definitely have and
known pauline transporters vasilis atlas
is unusual neck it has no recognizable
homologue of the famous hot ABCD
transporter that was first found in an
equal I which transports really so add
to come to biofilms apology is for you
biofilm experts but i'm just going to
explain simply what a biofilm is if
anybody is unfamiliar now for 100 years
it was thought that bacteria grew as we
grow them in a laboratory they grow
planktonic lee in liquid and they grow
fast but in reality bacteria growing
surfaces in community inside a matrix
approaching and polysaccharide so this
matrix is called the biofilm and it
actually is the main way which back to
your own nature and if you want to feel
some by phone you can rub your finger
over your teeth and you hang a slimy
thing is the buyer phone or if you're
more squeamish
you can rub your finger on the head of
your shower and often shower heads a
little bit biofilm on them Amy the key
feature of a biofilm is that the
bacteria protected because and they're
inside this three-dimensional matrix
apart cycloidal protein which
occasionally has DNA sometimes lipids
and the bifold is made by the bacteria
of themselves they excrete the power
cycle item and cooking and so by farmers
are very important in medicine because
of course I films cover catheters and
prosthetic hip replacements etc even
contact lenses and they allow bacteria
to persist and they also help the
bacteria to become resistant to
antibiotics by basically repelling equus
phase where anti-politics around so the
antibiotics actually just can't get into
the bacterial cell because they can't
get through the buyer from the crooks
now and the first observations of poly
is being involved by a confirmation are
from ten years ago it was first noticed
that Google Chrome Web items were
actually stimulated by the external
application of loss pervading which is
appointment made by the block all right
but if you supply most and begin
exogenously that is if you put it into
the growth medium libera powered by
phones can be stimulated by up to 20
fold and what's more it seems that a
protein called nsps and senses the level
of NOS permitting and NSPS is a
homologue of the substrate binding
protein of the spermidine uptick
transporter so that was quite an
intriguing result now and not long after
that paper was published
regroup of Marcus Olivia from that poly
means are essential provide confirmation
in the plague bacterium Yersinia pestis
they originally noticed that if they
knock the planning production in Yesenia
they could restore by from formation
with peak Racine but not responding to
the original paper it was thought that
only Peterson was necessary subsequently
another paper they described that same
pest is the play bacterium can't take up
external security so it's likely that
the important back tip the important
partying in my confirmation would plague
bacterium disability but anyway here we
have a role of poly means by
confirmation of two incredibly important
pathogens for Bakura and using a pestis
figures after that my group showed that
internal north building production
rubicon i was important provide
confirmation and Tommy Lee showed that
NOS permitting is Nate integral annoyed
by an alternative pathway that was not
known at the time although individual
enzymes had been worked on by people for
several years but anyway in liberal
caller ID your coumadin is essential for
by for collision and the function of
north building and biofilm formation
cannot be replaced by sperma d then we
looked at and bacillus at risk Polly
mean by synthesis and it's rolling back
confirmation and I remind you that
earlier I said that the suicide list
doesn't require poly means at all from
platonic growth however it has a
dependency on sperma dean for bio
confirmation so here we have an
interesting system where by confirmation
and growth are disconnected as far as
poly mean physiology is concerned now
and before i go to show you some
examples of bacillus iphones most people
working with by phones work with so much
my phones and they measure by
confirmation of submerged biofilms in
microtiter dishes you bro the biofilm in
the wells of microtiter dish if stained
the biometrics with crystal violet so
you can then measure the amount of
staining isn't click reader you also
have to compensate for the effect on
planktonic growth and the great thing
about plate reader is that you can
continuously monitor growth and you can
also measure crystal violet staining so
you can then distinguish between effects
of planktonic growth and effects on bio
from of course if and you're looking at
a molecule that inhibits growth and it
will probably in hit by a confirmation
there is a paper out from the group of
binkow in Singapore where they showed
that ensuring ella anand Isis that when
you knock out Peterson production it
increases by a full provision so that's
an interesting and opposite of the trend
to what I've just described so in show
an hour which is a gamma proteobacteria
probably means inhibit by a confirmation
and if you knock out protein production
it increases poly as biofilm formation
now I'm going to talk a little bit about
bacillus atlas because we've worked on
this for the last couple of years this
is a floating biofilm of bacillus Atlas
with the biofilm forms at the interface
between the liquid culture and the air
although these biofilms i'm showing you
the pellicle by hamza crop they look the
same size in fact they've just been
adjusted to the same science they've
cranked are from different sized
microtiter dishes and dependent upon
what you want to look at sometimes it's
better to work with a large powerful six
well I protected issue sometimes you
want to do lots of experiments of you
use a 24-well and micro tech division
and the main difference is you just get
more resolution to the biofilm in the
larger iphone 6 well and both of
wrinkles are described as the velocity
of the biome and it's thought that the
wrinkling is a direct measure of the
robustness of the matrix production now
your business settlers biofilms formed
on a solid surface they call complex
call me back phones and these biofilms
that I'm sure you are to scale so at the
top is a wild-type by from and at the
bottom are two mutants appointing
biosynthesis and what happens when you
knock out corning production facilities
is you lose that very robust ring clip
however in these very high-resolution
photographs if you look closely even in
the mutant you can see very tiny
wrinkles so it isn't that by
confirmation has gone completely but you
don't get the robust by confirmation of
the wild-type and and here we have a
comparison of a company by phone on top
and the pellicle by home that is on the
liquid and below and on the left we have
the wild-type version and on the right
we have a spermidine auxotrophic mutant
so the complex biofilm is greatly
reduced when you knock out experimenting
production and the wrinkling of calico
by from is greatly reduced below it just
shows that that
one approach of the wild type of the
mutant overlap completely so there is no
effect on planktonic roof of naka nuts
ability in production on the umpire
confirmation now for the next five or
ten minutes have just gotta talk about
slightly uncomfortable episode in this
field for the last couple of years this
paper came out in 2012 itself I'm not
going to say who the authors are you can
look it up if you want to but anyway in
this paper which was published itself
and they claim that the poly in north
bergen was produced by bacillus in order
to disassemble the biofilm so when this
came out this was very good news because
any molecule that can disassemble
biofilms is very valuable yeah it would
help you to connect antibiotic
resistance on things like catheters and
replacements so this was need a very big
paper however when I read the paper as a
biochemist I realized that the by
synthetic pathway proposed to know
sperma d in this paper just didn't exist
in ampicillin settlers for the law we'd
never detected no sperm reading in
bacillus atlas ourselves my collaborator
in Dundee and also had some doubts and
so I will just list the key features of
the paper but were all somewhat
questionable so the first claim was that
most feminine inhibits bacillus Atlas
iPhones and just 25 my parole oh that's
a very low concentration for Pauline
boots because sperm adine for instance
in Brazil setlist is present in about
six millimolar at 6,000 micromolar it
was also claimed that self additional
spermidine is found in the bio follows
and
5218 micromolar and by our hplc methods
you should have detected that it was
there they also claim that the
inhibitory action of north from being on
biofilms is due to binding to the
exopolysaccharide I'm not going to talk
about the biochemical aspect because
that's a little bit boring for anybody
who's not an aficionado of I synthetic
pathways but i'll talk about the aspect
of x from physiology now my collaborator
liquids Pamella Roland her bedpost up
Laura hobby contrary to a finding of the
cell paper that loss over Dean inhibited
by confirmation they found that if you
had a mutant are pulling biosynthesis so
here if we look along a top n CI b 36 10
is the wild-type strain of bacillus
atlas and you can see that it forms a
nice biofilm on msgg medium which is the
chemically defined medium purpose or
settlers taz a is a mutant of the
protein component of the Python EPS is
an intent of the genes that weekly
exopolysaccharide spy a is allocation of
arginine detox like so no poly means
could be made in Spain mutant and speedy
is a gene for the demo problem
biosynthetic pathway to speedy Newton's
can make Peterson but not scrummaging
then if you grow the mutants on hundred
McMorris pyridine and especially 200
micro molar spending by from permission
is restored but what Nicola and Alana
found is that no spell meeting was even
better than spiriting at restoring by
flocculation so this was perplexing
because the original cell paper said
that no sperm being inhibited by
confirmation so what could be going on
and we also looked at a mutant of
exopolysaccharide in the biofilm and we
found that if you grew restless in
liquid in different concentrations on of
sperm being eventually the Norse
pyrimidine inhibited the planktonic
growth are pasilla surface so if you
inhibit planktonic roof you will inhibit
by confirmation because the by phone
yield is dependent upon the amount of
sales that you have in a culture and in
fact the mutant of X applause I'm
exopolysaccharide production was as
sensitive to most government being as
was the one type and at the bottom we
have grown the wild-type by from on
different concentrations in Australian
and also the exopolysaccharide mutant
and if you notice with the
exopolysaccharide mutant for the first
four panels you can see some wispy
failed by phone but it then disappears
at the same time that the biofilm of the
wild-type disappears at point five
minimal and most riveting and that's
because there are just no cells there so
reason why you get any inhibition of my
confirmation is because you have an
invasion of growth similarly if we grew
and the wild-type or Newton's upon you
by synthesis at 25 michael moore's law
spending which according to the south
paper should inhibit by a confirmation
we actually got more wrinkly and when we
grew them on a hundred micro molar mass
building on the right hand side we had
extremely robust iphones much more so
than just that with no Polly minute or
25 Michael over so even with quanta
concentration of NOS billion four times
higher than inhibitory concentration
described in the sale paper we got very
robust by confirmation and the cell
paper claimed that
Ross building was present in the
biofilms at about 50 to 80 micromolar
and here we analyzed by foam material
and if you look to the left the peak
that is no spam lean n SPD we tried
different concentrations and at the
bottom in red that's a level of 0.5
matter over which we can be tanked
easily in blank is where we haven't
added no spelled in it's just the
bacillus but suicide was by film itself
and there is no detectable no spam
billing in these bio phones so if there
really was 50 to 80 micromolar the
people would be bigger than the pikas
permitting we see in the center of the
hplc trace so clearly and there was some
serious error in the detection of most
permitting in the original sound paper
and to cut a long story short we
published our findings in cell which
contradicted the earlier self paper and
then about a year later the original
group published a retraction of their
paper there be a key take-home message
of this is that if we hadn't published
our paper the first paper would not have
been retracted and I note that the
original paper was cited more times
after our paper came out than before
i'll be working out so this is a lesson
in how you must read papers very
carefully and forensically never take it
as true just because it's in a big job
and the summary of my talk is that and
like a new carrots rapala means are
absolutely central to both in bacteria
there is no universally conservative
function and the physiological role
bacterial colonies of bacteria has
diversified and I should add that not
just
by a confirmation improve but polymers
are used to make all sorts of natural
products such as siderophores in
bacteria which bind iron and they make a
kind of natural product so the natural
history of calling into bacteria is
extremely rich but it means that it's
not easy to get a single idea of the
ruler pronotal bacteria the many roles
and finally Norse permanent is not
produced by bacillus Atlas and it
doesn't have a native program by country
physiology in the species so at at the
end of my talk and thank you for
listening thank you for that informative
presentation before we get started on
the question and answer session I would
like to remind our audience how to
submit questions you can submit
questions by typing them in the Q&A box
which can be found by clicking on the
green Q&A button at the lower left of
the presentation window we will try to
answer as many questions as we can and I
just want to give people a chance to to
ask their questions so okay so um it
appears that um oh how can we disperse
biofilm with your knowledge on poly
Amiens
and I think that it should be possible
to design new types of poly means that
bacteria and could modify so that they
get incorporated into the biofilm and
make it weaker or we could attach
certain groups to poly means so that the
poem in might be taken into the cell and
the group that we've attached to the
poly mean may be toxic a so-called
program horse approach where we
essentially weaponize the poly meaning
the polling transporter is rather
flexible so you can get various
structural variations putting you
through the Pauline transporter and
groups like the group of otto Frank
steel in university Central Florida
attached nasty things like napthalene to
poly means but that's for eukaryotic
cells very few people have published on
this but I know that a lot of people
work in line I hope that was on two
dishes there are no further questions I
would like to once again thank dr.
Michael for his presentation do you have
any final comments dr. Michael and well
if anybody does have any questions are
welcome to email me today's webcast will
be available for on-demand viewing
through februari 2016 you'll receive an
email from lab roots alerting you when
this webcast will be available for
replay we invite you to forth an
announcement to your colleagues to may
have missed today's live event see you
next time bye
you